hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy so if you recall
from part 11 on lipids we talked about
steroids and we talked about cholesterol
specifically we said that it was the
major sterile in animals it was really
really important it also maintains
membrane fluidity it's also amphipathic
and v Pathak or amphiphilic and it's
also a steroid precursor so it's a
really really important molecule now the
question is how do we make it how do we
make it well there are actually four
stages in involved in making cholesterol
the first one is methyl on a synthesis I
do want to comment on this and say that
they're called stages not steps because
each stage has many steps so the first
one yes is mevalonate synthesis and
we're taking we're going to be making
mevalonic from acetyl co a z' acetyl co
a so here we're starting off with 3
acetyl co is here each one is 2 carbons
two carbons long and we're going to take
them and combine them together to make
this molecule here which is methyl on 8
which is 6 carbons long so all 3 of
these two carbon molecules will come
together to make methyl on 8 now once we
have metal on 8 the next thing we're
going to do the next stage so this here
I guess I'll jot this down here this is
stage 1 stage 2 here is is called ISO 10
penal pyrophosphate pyrophosphate
synthesis or IPP synthesis this of
course is made from mevalonate so this
molecule here is IPP isopentenyl
pyrophosphate and it's a 5 carbon
molecule that's the the pent pent it
they're referring to the 5 carbons so
member lenay being 6 carbons long
isopentenyl pyrophosphate being 5
carbons long we lose a carbon there as a
carbon dioxide it we'll see more about
that later so that's stage 2 stage 3
squalene synthesis squalene synthesis
which is made from the condensation of
six IPP molecules so we're going to take
six of these isopentane o pyrophosphates
in stage three and we're going to
combine them together to make this
molecule called squalene which is this
here squalene rather large so squalene
given that there are six isopentenyl
pyrophosphate that are going to be
combined to make squalene six times five
gives you these 30 carbons so that's
stage 3 stage for the last stage the
last stage is called squalene
cyclization siccolas ation and that's
when we're actually going to form the
steroid nucleus that is those four rings
right the steroid nucleus the ABC and D
rings in cholesterol and in that fourth
stage we're also going to be this is
going to include the modifications like
oxidation as well as the removal of the
three carbons because cholesterol has 27
carbons you see here whereas quailing
has 30 so we're going to take this
squalene with its 30 carbons and in
stage 4 stage 4 here we're going to
convert it into cholesterol which looks
like that we've seen that already so in
that and those phenols
in that fourth stage we're going to lose
3 carbons to give us this final product
cholesterol so in the next few videos
we're going to be sort of going over
these 4 stages in a little bit more
detail hope that video is helpful thank
you for watching thanks for watching and
be sure to LIKE comment subscribe and
share the video with anyone new theme
might find it helpful thanks happy
studying